now to the house select committee
investigating the January 6 assault on
the capitol which will hold its last
planned public Hearing in just a few
hours committee members say they will
share never before seen images and
Revelations about the attack and new
information about former president
Trump's role in a plot to overturn the
election results Scott McFarland is on
Capitol Hill with a preview for us Scott
good morning to you
Gail good morning this hearing will look
and sound different there'll be no live
Witnesses this time and all nine panel
members will make part of this closing
argument with just weeks remaining for
the committee to wrap up its work
the house January 6 select committee is
not only attempting to show some of its
newest findings but also trying to
regain America's attention
the committee staffers conducted a long
sought-after interview with conservative
activist Ginny Thomas wife of Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas the
committee says she was urging the Trump
White House to fight the 2020 election
results we still have significant
information that we've not shown to the
public committee Vice chair Liz Cheney
says the secret service has provided
hundreds of thousands of pages of
communication after the agency revealed
requested text messages had been deleted
the panel says it will also focus on
Trump's State of Mind ahead of and
during the attack and will show what
they call his centrality in this scheme
to overturn the election it's important
for people to know that this wasn't
spontaneous that this was directed and
that the president of the United States
whose first responsibility is to keep
America safe
refused and did not do that on January
6th meanwhile a documentary filmmaker
tells CBS News he's provided footage to
the committee ahead of today's hearing
from his film about Trump Ally Roger
Stone you've shared some of your
recording with the house January 6
select committee could you tell what
part of this they were interested in
their focus was the connections between
Roger Stone The Oath Keepers and the
proud boys that is the groups that were
spearheading the attacks on January 6.
the committee will also issue a final
written report it must do so by the end
of December and all of this is happening
against the backdrop of the midterm
elections which Gale are now less than
four weeks away
I know we are all counting and waiting
for that but Scott we hear that there's
other stories involving Mr Trump today
that there's no information we're
hearing from the investigation of
documents that are marked as classified
that were removed from Mar-A-Lago what
can you tell us about that
that's right Gail an individual familiar
with the investigation tells CBS News
investigators have spoken to a witness
who works at Mar-A-Lago and says the
former president directed him or her to
move boxes containing documents after
Trump advisors received a subpoena in
May the handling of the boxes and the
documents were part of the FBI's
reasoning to get a warrant this
individual is cooperating has spoken
with a grand jury here in Washington and
there is video evidence of boxes being
handled Gail
all right Scott thank you very much
that's an interesting new development
thanks a lot we'll bring you live
coverage of today's January 6 Committee
hearing in a CBS News special special
report we're expected to start that at
one o'clock Eastern time today